hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber so
we got Dan here and he's on hiatus right
now pulled them out of hiatus in order
to watch a trailer with me yeah it's
easy when you don't have to edit I just
need to show up half drunk and then do
things that is how I still do things
even with the setting up we had 13 beers
before we style it's been good I do have
some Negra Modelo yeah and we're gonna
watch the trailer today for final
fantasy 15 the neverending franchise
it's like the Bond movies it is the TGS
trailer which as you guys know is the
broadcasting channel that airs Conan and
it's devious its tuberculosis station
couldn't help yourself could you
no man you have to do it do it not more
of a day ever since this was Final
Fantasy 13 versus I've been excited for
this game because looks just [ __ ]
bad-ass two and a half minutes of
Awesomeness gameplay trailer so this is
the final
I love you Japan
it's the mantra yeah
boy can she
I do
questioner tomorrow
dr. Wow look at those graphics dude yeah
square-enix knows how to make a damn
fine-looking babe
to a cleaner
Oh
Paulina certainly has
for work in progress that is dude pretty
amazing oh my god that looks awesome
like seriously it does look like a blast
I love modern-day fantasy or whatever
the hell this is well yeah well it's
interesting because final fantasy like
seven and eight had this more sort of
like steampunk sort of mm thing more is
a lot a lot of technology involved with
the thing and then they went more like a
lot like almost strictly fantasy with
some of the other iterations since and
this is kind of a returning to like this
sort of like blended world of like magic
and modern technology and all that sort
of stuff and goddamn it looks great
comment looks [ __ ] great in the case
I see the content and the characters
have personality which is also a lot of
fun to - absolutely yeah you know it's
better than just some like
straightforward kind of or super serious
it's like these guys have a sense of
humor yeah and I find that very much
admirable cuz it's usually some really
serious leading characters or something
so it's cool to see a little road trip
going on well it's good it's a road trip
game literally it is Final Fantasy beats
Entourage
yeah that's exactly what it looked like
actually that's so crazy
ya know that looks awesome but let's
face it the best Final Fantasy was the
spirits for them to film a movie that's
the greatest final fantasy adventure
ever hands down I can give you the
address if you want to kill him this is
just facts statistics say since it is so
tissu say this nobles in goodnight
I think you've misread the statistics I
did not read it a red bar was definitely
telling me what's right the red bar yeah
the red bar was as a bar graph there was
a bar graph let me let me ask you
something was it going up or down well
did the lower is the better gosh did you
not go to school do you even math uh
yeah
count my money that I make up yeah oh
the dollar bills are on you it's right
breaking the fourth wall alright thanks
for all you mother effers for
recommending this video if you're new to
the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and dan has a gaming channel you better
subscribe to that [ __ ] because when I
get back and he gets back it's gonna be
nonstop gameplay fun right
I'm Monday Wednesdays and Fridays or no
stops periodically but three days a week
of fun nay hacks five snacks five oh I
remember you I love your channel it's so
funny but still has great content I just
started my movie review channel and it
doesn't have much of an audience I feel
pretty dad for doing this but could I
get a shout-out it's nowhere as cool as
you guys are but I do love movies and
enjoy what I do
I would appreciate it so much stay happy
guys snake x5 I've seen your reviews
you're doing a good job I'm gonna give
you some tips though one you need more
dick jokes too you're a woman
they'll be funny if you talk about your
vagina 3 maybe get a microphone a
beginner microphone maybe does she not
have one I don't think so but I've been
pretty sure these the first two I mean
if you could do the first two well you
can survive without a microphone for a
while all you need is your face that
moneymaker that face and some good
genital jokes that you cannot hear
because there's no microphone built-in
microphone in the camera you know I mean
like it's you know like when you start
making them dollar bills
get a nice microphone to ride that is
the worst advice you could ever get yeah
that's actually pretty bad advice Dionne
Bandula
on the babadook trailer number 2
reaction he said first Seabra shoutout
wow he earned his shout out by being
burst Dionne sounds like de Jong it's
like he came in yelled like ran into
that door you'll first okay bye
like walked out and then we heard of
like down the street yo li'l Dionne
mandola your request has been heard and
here we are talking about you mandola
you know that's the type of instrument
mmm yeah is it yeah well it's not so
much an instrument it's the drums were
women bangs it on her boobs what the
boob bein like if you have a big breasts
yeah okay that's the band Ola that's
what they call it but man
is boob boob Drummond boob Drummond well
then I'm an expert Brooks
alley-oop don't poop in it
dem guys yes or another shout out you
got to look for a man because I already
gave you one boy frost same thing for
you Jim Weaver hey I am 58 my wife of
over 40 awesome years loves that I watch
you guys she tells me it is good because
you guys make me laugh and my health
problems laughing is a great healer not
trying to get you down just thought I
would give you a shout out from an old
hippie thanks again and enjoy life it is
too short to waste peace that is cool
that's really cool that's cool I got a
58 year old subscriber that is awesome
it's just [ __ ] cool that I'm glad
good I mean mostly him but every now and
then that I'm on and glad we can make
you laugh and stuff mainly just me keep
yourself at us damn I'm trying to have
like a [ __ ] heartfelt moment yeah
it's not working all free dick he likes
the dick jokes come on man [ __ ] it see
58 he might be able to hook us up with
viagra I am NOT doing viagra oh come on
we'll do our together yes so I and then
what I don't know we weave our penises
together no you know the doors that way
nope take care dad Jim thank you